Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Thirteen: N.F.S.
Grundtvig, Danishness, folk high schools and church life.
The priest, hymn writer and social commentator Nikolai Frederik Severin Grundtvig, who lived from 1783 to 1872, became a central figure in the development of thinking, culture and association life in Denmark in the 1800s.
His thoughts have also had very great influence on present-day Danish self-understanding.
Grundtvig was a theologian and worked most of his life as a priest, but his extensive involvement in social life and thoughts about what it meant to be Danish came during the 1800s to play a decisive role in the development of the broad population's national awareness, that is, its shared understanding of what it means to be Danish.
In other words, what is today often called "danskhed", Danishness.
He lived in the time when Denmark, with the loss of Norway, in 1814, and of Schleswig and Holstein, in 1864, became a small state, but in return got a uniform population where practically everyone spoke Danish.
That created the basis for a country with high social cohesion and was decisive for Grundtvig's ideas.
The popular became the national.
Grundtvig had many thoughts about how the population, who until then had obeyed the king's decisions without resistance, could become competent and equal citizens.
Central in Grundtvig's way of thinking was the concept "folkelighed", which meant that he took his starting point in the people, ordinary people and not, as before, the elites, for example the lords of the manor, the academics or the wealthy middle class.
This was the basis for all his thinking.
Folkelighed became for him a positive concept, which was to be central in everything, among other things in laws, rules, institutions and behaviour, which should therefore take their starting point in the broad population's, especially the rural population's, culture, way of life and view of the world.
And through broadly based enlightenment and education everyone was to be made part of the great national community.
In this way the social groups that until then had understood themselves as quite separate could be brought together into one united people, a nation.
The folk high school, højskolen.
Grundtvig's ideas also became the basis for the folk high school movement, højskolebevægelsen.
The folk high school, folkehøjskolen, was, according to Grundtvig, to be different from the existing schools and universities.
Here the students were not to learn by heart or take exams.
The teaching was instead to be based on "the living word".
The students were to learn to be curious and discuss.
The population was to "learn for life" at the folk high schools, to be enlightened in a broad sense about subjects such as for example Danish history, poetry or natural science.
In that way they could become competent citizens with responsibility both for themselves and for the whole.
Important parts of folk high school life were lectures and community singing.
Since 1894 the Folk High School Songbook, Højskolesangbogen, has come out in many editions.
It contains numerous patriotic songs and hymns, which among others Grundtvig himself has written.
The folk high school was aimed especially at young men and women from the rural environment, in practice the children of farmers, bøndernes børn, not the children of the estate owners, godsejernes børn, and not workers' children.
They had, in Grundtvig's opinion, a particular need for teaching that could awaken the students' natural interest and zest for life and thereby develop them into active and engaged fellow citizens.
The first Grundtvigian folk high school was opened in 1844 in Rødding in South Jutland, and soon many more followed all over the country.
Here the young people from the countryside could, on a winter's stay, get inspiration for their future active life at home in the local community.
It was, among other things, this better education of the rural population through folk high school stays that led to the great success of the cooperative movement at the end of the 1800s.
The importance of the folk high school movement became smaller as industrialisation progressed.
During the 1900s agriculture gradually lost importance, the move from country to town gathered speed, and the traditional school system was expanded.
Today the folk high schools are aimed especially at young people from the towns, who after the upper secondary school leaving exam want to develop personally before beginning a higher education.
Several present-day folk high schools have gradually become specialised theme schools, where for example sport or music is practised at elite level.
This type of folk high school has thereby moved somewhat away from Grundtvig's original idea of the folk high school as the nerve of general popular enlightenment.
Grundtvig and the national church.
Grundtvig also had great influence on Danish church life.
He has thus lent his name to the Danish national church's dominant direction, Grundtvigianism, which builds on an undogmatic understanding of Christianity with a starting point in joy of life.
Grundtvig first formulated his view of Christianity in 1832 with an expression that was typical of him, namely: "Menneske først – kristen så", "Human first, Christian then".
It is also because of Grundtvig that the designation "folke-" is part of the name of many words such as Folketing, folkehøjskole, folkeskole, folkebibliotek and so on.
Grundtvig was also a member of the Constitutional Assembly, Den grundlovsgivende Rigsforsamling, which drew up Denmark's first democratic constitution, which came into force on the fifth of June 1849.
It was especially due to his effort here that the Danish church has never become a state church.
The modern Danish church is a national church, folkekirke, which is supported by the state, but otherwise carries out its functions according to rules which the church itself lays down.
This is entirely in line with Grundtvig's thoughts about folkelighed, which also underlie the way the Danish nation sees itself.
Grundtvig's hymns and songs.
Besides his church and political work, Grundtvig was Denmark's most productive author of patriotic songs and hymns.
In the course of his long life he thus wrote more than 1,500, and many of them are still found in the Folk High School Songbook and in Den Danske Salmebog, the Danish Hymnbook.
At almost all Danish church weddings, "Det er så yndigt at følges ad", "It is so lovely to walk together", is sung, and every New Year shortly after midnight many drink champagne and eat kransekage to the tones of "Vær velkommen, Herrens år", "Welcome, year of the Lord", both written by Grundtvig.
Here is your recap for Episode Thirteen.
Grundtvig, 1783 to 1872, was a priest, hymn writer and social commentator.
The key concept in his thinking was folkelighed, starting from ordinary people.
Denmark became a small state after losing Norway in 1814 and Schleswig and Holstein in 1864.
The folk high school should teach through "the living word", without exams.
The first Grundtvigian folk high school opened in 1844 in Rødding in South Jutland.
The Højskolesangbogen has come out since 1894.
The better education of the rural population helped the cooperative movement succeed.
Grundtvigianism is the dominant direction in the national church; his motto was "Menneske først, kristen så", formulated in 1832.
He was a member of the Constitutional Assembly of 1849 and helped prevent a state church.
He wrote more than 1,500 hymns and songs, in the Højskolesangbogen and Den Danske Salmebog, including "Det er så yndigt at følges ad" at church weddings, and "Vær velkommen, Herrens år" at New Year.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which group of young people were there the most of at the folk high schools in the 1800s?
Option A: Children of estate owners.
Option B: Children of workers.
Option C: Children of farmers.
[DA] Hvilken gruppe unge var der flest af på højskolerne i 1800-tallet?  A: Godsejernes børn  |  B: Arbejdernes børn  |  C: Bøndernes børn
The answer is C: Children of farmers.
It appeared in the June 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Bøndernes børn
Question 2.
Which movement did Grundtvig have a special importance for in the 1800s?
Option A: The folk high school movement.
Option B: The labour movement.
Option C: The resistance movement.
[DA] Hvilken bevægelse fik Grundtvig i særlig grad betydning for i 1800-tallet?  A: Højskolebevægelsen  |  B: Arbejderbevægelsen  |  C: Modstandsbevægelsen
The answer is A: The folk high school movement.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Højskolebevægelsen
Question 3.
Which of the following persons gave inspiration in the 1800s to the founding of folk high schools?
Option A: Thomas Kingo.
Option B: Johannes V.
Jensen.
Option C: N.F.S.
Grundtvig.
[DA] Hvilken af følgende personer gav i 1800-tallet inspiration til oprettelsen af folkehøjskoler?  A: Thomas Kingo  |  B: Johannes V. Jensen  |  C: N.F.S. Grundtvig
The answer is C: N.F.S.
Grundtvig.
It appeared in the June 2021 and May 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: N.F.S. Grundtvig
Question 4.
Who wrote a large number of the hymns in Den Danske Salmebog?
Option A: Herman Bang.
Option B: Ludvig Holberg.
Option C: N.F.S.
Grundtvig.
[DA] Hvem har skrevet et stort antal af salmerne i Den Danske Salmebog?  A: Herman Bang  |  B: Ludvig Holberg  |  C: N.F.S. Grundtvig
The answer is C: N.F.S.
Grundtvig.
It appeared in the June 2022 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: N.F.S. Grundtvig
That's the end of this part.
Well done.